[Music]
if you land on their Instagram page on
their YouTube page what are some of the
biggest mistakes you think people are
making inconsistency is number one
inconsistency of posting focus on
creating great relationships focus on
using social media to connect with
people and build Relationships by
providing value to other people so that
then you can get in front of their
audience social media is supposed to be
social and another mistake I see people
making is they post and ghost they'll
post something and then they'll get
comments you want them to engage you
want them to comment and then you don't
respond
so how do you find your audience amplify
your brand and ultimately stand out
online Our Guest today is Jen gotle the
author of be seen and this is going to
be a powerp packed episode where we're
going to be talking about mindset shifts
and Powerful tips around being
courageous and getting out there with
your message being creative being more
connected with some networking tips and
then ultimately how can we be more
visible as well with our content with
our brands with our businesses and so as
a content creator as an entrepreneur
stick around because this is going to be
a powerp packed episode now Jen is a
Powerhouse entrepreneur an international
speaker host of the I Dare You podcast
co-founder of super connector media and
does a lot of super cool things she
shared the stage with all kinds of top
people like Gary vaynerchuk Marie forio
Eric Thomas most recently Oprah and uh
Snoop Dogg Martha Stewart and we're
super excited about our new book bcen
Jen welcome to the show I'm so excited
to be here so for people that are just
meeting you um how do you elevator pitch
if someone's like what do you actually
do how do you answer that question I
help entrepreneurs and thought leaders
or anybody with a service a story or a
product build a profitable brand online
but ultimately I help people be seen I
love that and how is it that you gained
that expertise and got to where you are
today well if you want to go way way way
back every single entrepreneurial like
lesson I've ever learned in my life came
from my acting career so I started my
whole career as an actress and moved to
New York City when I was 20 I dropped
out of college I actually I went to
school for musical theater at the
University of Harford and I realized
within like one semester the college was
not for me and I needed to move to New
York City and pursue my dream moved to
New York went to a 2-year Conservatory
program for musical theater to learn how
to be a Broadway actor learn how to sing
and dance and act and I went out into
the world and I ended up uh booking my
dream role in the Broadway national tour
of The Wedding Singer have you seen it
no the Adam Sandler Drew movie yes okay
yeah I've seen it the movie Yes exactly
so they made a musical out of it I
toured the world the world I toured the
country with this show for a year
playing my dream role and realized while
I'm touring the country on a bus
performing doing the thing that I
thought that I was born to do 10 shows a
week again and again and again kind of
sort of like realizing oh my God this
isn't what I thought it was going to be
I don't know if I want this and then I
came home and I booked a TV show on VH1
all about heavy metal music I don't like
heavy metal music oh no but I got this
job job and I was an actress and I
needed a job and I was like this is
amazing okay a show on VH1 I got this
gig I'm going to do everything that I
can to keep this gig and to keep up this
act and before I knew it I had built
this brand that couldn't have been
further from who I really was MH and I
was being seen online as a version of
myself that was completely opposite to
who I was in real life and I was totally
like I believe that when you're out of
alignment in the brand that you're
showing to the world even if you're not
a business owner an entrepreneur your
brand like who you are to the world if
you are coming off as fake or if you're
just lying and you're trying to keep up
like all of the shs for everybody else
what you should look like what you
should sound like what you should be
like you start to disconnect from who
you really are and you start to really
just disconnect from everything that you
desire and I I just spiraled and when
you're out of alignment with yourself I
believe which I was the universe will
sometimes step in and like smack you
back into alignment and a lot of the
times it'll hurt and that's what
happened to me and everything was pretty
much taken from me in like a week the
show got cancelled this guy that I was
dating that I thought I was going to
marry ended up leaving me for one of our
friends and I was in this horrible place
where I was pretending to be somebody
that I wasn't and I was partying I was
severely bulimic I was in a really deep
depression because I was like who the
hell am I this isn't right for me I
don't know what my path is and so I
found myself in this tiny little room
with a window that faced a wall and like
six other actors like in this apartment
and not knowing who I was or what I
wanted to do and I was forced not not
cuz I wanted to but I was forced to
figure it out and it took me a while and
it took a lot of businesses to get to
where I am today and I tried a lot of
different things but over the process of
or over the course of time in recreating
myself again and again in building
separate different businesses I was a
personal trainer and then I was an
online coach and I was in the fitness
industry I learned how to build brand
and I learned how to promote myself but
more importantly I learned how to build
brand and promote myself as who I really
am and I found and I noticed that when
you show the world or your audience your
ideal audience your ideal Avatar who you
really are and you allow yourself to
just be who you are messily imperfectly
and you let them see the real you you
connect with the people that are your
ride or die with the people that are
going to buy forever with the people
that are going to build community with
you and not just be like likes on
Instagram or people that just follow and
never never do anything with you in the
future so throughout that process and
then meeting my husband and my business
partner we decided to come together and
teach other entrepreneurs and business
owners how to build that brand that's
not just the brand of what you think you
should be but the brand of who you truly
are so that it's easy and it feels fun
and you can truly connect with your
audience what do you think the pressures
are right now that might push a content
creator an entrepreneur somebody that's
using social media into something that's
less than authentically them like why do
you think maybe some people are falling
into the Trap that you fell into of
again not being in alignment or not
being authentic there's so many I mean
just pick up your phone and scroll pick
up your phone and scroll and what you
see when you pick up your phone is
obviously everybody highlight reel right
and I know that that's like so typical
everyone calls it the Highlight Reel but
it truly is because social media is a
beautiful place to Showcase all the
great things you're doing that's what
it's for and that's amazing you should
showcase all the great things in your
business you should showcase all the
great things that are happening in your
life but what's not happening is people
aren't necessarily going on and talking
about the real stuff that's happening
behind the scenes so it's really easy to
think that you are so alone in whatever
mess is going on because you're
scrolling and you're seeing all these
fabulous things all these filtered
images all of these maybe maybe fake
vacations maybe fake private jet
situations maybe fake rented cars all of
this stuff and it's coming at us and
that's what we're looking at and that's
why we're surrounded with all the time
and so subconsciously we start to build
this belief that whatever is going on in
our life just isn't good enough because
it doesn't look like that but we have to
remember that that's not real and so I
see a lot of people that come to me a
lot of our clients a lot of people that
DM me they're like Jen like I I I've
been doing the thing that I thought I
needed to do in order to Be Perfect
online because I'm following all these
people and I'm seeing what they're doing
but I'm just feeling like it's not me
and it's so hard to keep up with and I'm
like what would happen if you just
allowed yourself to take down the
filter to just take a deep breath and
understand and know that the thing that
is the messiest about you the thing that
is the most human about you is probably
going to be the thing that a helps the
most people and B attracts the most
people and I learned that actually
recently so I never used to really be
okay with being on camera with like no
makeup on that was always something even
when I started building my brand as like
what I like to call like real genen like
not heavy metal gen that was going on
before but like being me I still had
this like filter up this was before I
wrote the book and everything and I felt
that I wasn't being completely authentic
uh a really good friend of mine who
actually just passed away Jesse Lee uh
and I want to mention her name always
when I tell the story because she gave
me this advice we were in a mastermind
together and we were sitting uh like at
this dinner and she was like you know
what you should do you should really go
live on Instagram with no makeup on and
put your makeup on while you go live and
I'm like that's a terrible idea I would
never do that are you crazy cuz that
felt scary and vulnerable and no way in
hell would I do that and I when the
morning that I woke up and thought that
I was going to write a book I was like
you know I need to allow myself to be
seen and fully connect with people
otherwise no one's going to want to buy
a book from me no one's going to want to
learn how to be seen from me no one's
going to want to learn from me if they
just think that everything in my life is
perfect tomorrow morning I'm going to go
live like what Jesse Lee said and I'm
going to put my makeup on and if no one
shows up it's okay I don't care I'm just
going to go go on there and see what
happens so I did it and it was scary and
not a lot of people showed up and it
wasn't that much fun and I wasn't very
good however I made a commitment to
myself and I kept doing it and now I do
this every single day Monday through
Friday I go live I put my makeup on and
I answer questions and I talk to people
this has been the best content strategy
that I ever implemented in my business
ever to this day wow ever it's the best
lead generator it's the best people are
connecting with each other I've created
community on this Instagram live they're
all going out to dinner with each other
they're all coming to my event together
they're all they're all like part of
this group they've all become part of my
street team for my book they all buy
whatever it is I'm selling whether
that's a free thing or or a paid thing
because we get ready together every
morning and because I'm allowing myself
to be real so maybe I've got a highlight
real when you look at my page and that's
great because I'm promoting myself but
there's this time in the morning that's
for one hour when I've got no makeup on
my face and I'm totally messy and
vulnerable and I'm practicing answering
people's questions I'm practicing
speaking I'm actually telling stories
and talking and answering questions
connecting that I'm real and I'm telling
them this is what's going on today it's
a I got my three dogs barking in the
background like my husband's running
back like we're we're yelling at each
other all this stuff is happening I'm
putting makeup on my face I've got an
eyelash in my hand and my hair is
sticking up and I'm putting in my hair
extensions and that not only helped my
algorithm which you could probably talk
about in a big way like I'm sure going
live really does help your algorithm and
I got a lot more engagement but it also
created a deep connection with my
customer my avatar my my dream audience
member what would you say to somebody
who says okay so maybe I should put
myself out there in a raw format be
vulnerable make up off share about maybe
my past or something I'm going through
that an eating disorder going through
addiction but what if somebody comes out
like it's so common in Internet comments
and it's cruel or what if it doesn't
work and what if while I hear you say
that I don't know if I want to try that
tomorrow morning what message would you
have for me yeah so the internet trolls
that's the first thing we'll talk about
because that's going to happen when when
you start to be seen and you start to
put yourself out there not everybody's
going to understand it not everybody's
going to like it but what I remember or
try to remind myself of whenever I
experience that is number one first of
all it doesn't feel good okay so I'm not
going to sit here and be like just
delete and block and it's okay because
it's not it sucks everyone wants to be
like nobody wants to get negative
feedback or comments on their posts but
my therapist always asks me her famous
question for me all the time is what do
you want your relationship with that to
be because we get to choose what our
perspective of that is we don't get to
choose like that it hurts and it stings
and like it doesn't feel good and it's
not fun and we don't get to choose if it
happens or not it's going to happen but
what do we want our relationship with it
to be and for me I'm going to understand
that anybody that's commenting on my
comments in a mean way or saying
something negative or saying something
nasty that is to hurt me or is to bring
me down I know that that person must be
in pain or must not be very happy
because I know a lot of happy and
successful people and I know that not
one of them would ever even dare to just
go on the internet and comment
negatively or something mean on
somebody's post so I just think okay I
feel really bad for this person I'm
going to have empathy for this person
and I'm going to understand and know
that this is the thing that I signed up
for that there was going to be people
like this on the internet that
unfortunately are sad and not so happy
and they're going to take it out on me
and my relationship with that is I'm
just going to think empathetically
towards them and send them love in my
mind and uh and understand and know that
my relationship with this is this is
what it is is how do I want to react
understand that this is part of the game
and move on and and try as hard as I
possibly can to not let it affect me in
a negative way or not keep me from
showing up because for every single
person that's on there talking smack
there's probably at least 20 30 40 50
other people that really liked that post
that really got a lot out of it and
maybe for some of those people it helped
them in a way that I don't even know
maybe some of the maybe there was
somebody if I posted about something
that was really a big deal for me maybe
the eating disorder that I experienced
uh and I post and talk about that openly
or I talk about it openly in the book
for every person that's like oh I can't
believe her that's gross or whatever or
might say something mean or negative
because it might activate them there
might be a woman out there that's like
wow I feel not alone now in this problem
and she really help me to be able to
like just flip my mindset around for
this day this one day or just not feel
alone in this today and that's why I do
what I do to help one person every day I
call it that the acronym that I use is
hope I just think about maybe that one
person that's on the other side of the
phone that needs to hear that today and
when I get up and every day if I get
nervous to go online with no makeup on
or share a messy part of my life or
share something that's going on that I'm
really afraid that people are going to
judge me for I think about the one
person that might need to hear that
today and I just Envision talking to
them that's powerful h o p yeah help one
person every day what a great social
media vision and a content creator
vision
and let's talk about branding
what is a brand H that's a good question
what is a brand I mean there's probably
a bazillion different definitions for
this so I'll give you what I think it is
yeah um for me your brand is your
essence your brand your brand can change
and your brand can shift and your brand
is actually who you are so I think that
people get it wrong when they think that
your brand is like your colors and your
fonts and your you know this thing that
you create uh because if you create your
brand and it's like this yes all of
those pieces come into the puzzle when
you're starting to build out your
website and all the things that you
create on the side but if you're looking
at it in the 2023 and Beyond realm like
everybody is a brand now everybody has a
virtual presence of some kind think
about it even if you're not a business
owner or you're not an entrepreneur or
you you just you don't even have
anything that you want to showcase on
the internet if I was in the dating
world and I connected with somebody on
an app on social media or whatever on an
app and I was going on a date with them
if I went online and they had no online
presence they had no brand online what
of whatso ever I wouldn't go out with
them cuz I would be like that's weird
like that is weird and that's scary and
that kind of freaks me out I want to see
something everybody has some Essence
online and it's not what you want to
create it to be and I think we get into
trouble when we try to do that who are
you genuinely my brand is everything
that I am it's not just that I wrote a
book it's not just that I'm a speaker
it's not just that I'm a business owner
it's also that I'm a New Yorker and I've
got three dogs and I like watching
baking shows but I don't bake I love
lifting weights like I have a really
loud high pitched voice sometimes uh I
you know there's all these like things
about me and it's just Jen it's who I am
and the cool thing about that about
making that my brand is that that can
evolve and change and grow as I evolve
and change and grow so if I choose that
I am this person I am heavy metal girl
and like that's it and I build
everything around that if I evolve and
change and grow and I have just
solidified my brand as one thing it's
going to be really really hard for me to
live my life authentically and it's
going to get really exhausting so if you
just make your brand who you are and you
allow it to grow and evolve with you and
it just is your essence like I don't
have a PR agency anymore great but
people follow me cuz I'm genen like all
the things that make me Jen not
necessarily what I do then everyone's
going to keep on following because it's
just me and I can keep growing and
evolving and that's my brand gotcha what
are some of the biggest mistakes you
think people are
making if you land on their Instagram
page on their YouTube page and you
assess it what are some of the common
mistakes You
observe that that man their brand needs
some work inconsistency is number one
inconsistency of posting I see a lot of
this they'll get really excited maybe
they went to an event or they listened
to a podcast or they watched one of your
videos and they got really stoked and
they're like okay I'm going to create
content and they go and they create a
piece of content every single day right
for a week and then they can't keep it
up because something happens and then
they give up on it and then a week later
they come back from not posting and
they're like I'm back I took a week away
from social media first of all no one
knew that you were gone so you don't
need to tell people that you're back
that's just telling people that you're
inconsistent and second of all if you do
start to make commitments with yourself
every single time you tell yourself
you're going to do something and you
don't follow through with it let's say
you commit to posting every single day
number one you're committing to yourself
number two you're committing to your
followers you are telling your
subconscious mind that you don't trust
yourself to follow through so you're
actually losing confidence within
yourself so it's not a good mindset hack
to not be consistent if you decide
you're going to build this brand and
you're going to post consistently but
also
your followers aren't going to want to
keep following you because they're not
going to trust you that they're going to
get the content every single day so
they're going to go follow someone else
that's consistent so consistency is the
number one thing that I need people to
focus on or I think that you should I
mean listen don't listen to me if you
don't want to but like consistency has
really helped me no matter what I'm
posting every day no matter what I'm
going live Monday through Friday I don't
care if I have to do it in the car on
the way to the airport or if I'm
actually putting my makeup on I stick
with the commitment I made with myself
and with my followers so that can count
on me and that's a big mistake that I
see people making lately is just not not
posting enough and not being consistent
with their content in the fourth section
of the book it's about be visible and
you share some advice on content
creation and marketing strategies to get
your message out there so what are some
of just maybe a handful of practical
tips obviously people can dive into the
book to get a lot of things but for
those that are stepping into the social
media World starting a YouTube channel
wanting to start creating content and
they're overwhelmed by the competition
yeah they're overwhelmed by how much
volume of content there is out there how
do you get seen and what are some advice
on content creation and marketing
strategies I've got so many okay so
we'll ner out a little bit and this goes
back to actually the mistakes that I see
people making as well so one of them
that can be unbelievably powerful for
somebody just starting out and it's not
necessarily about your numbers and how
many followers you have but how engaged
are those followers right how excited
are those followers to are to engage
with you and social media is supposed to
be social and another mistake I see
people making is they post and ghost or
they rip and dip they'll post something
and then they'll get comments people
will take time out of their day to give
the give you the greatest gift ever
which is a comment that's what you want
them to do you want them to engage you
want them to comment and then you don't
respond that is like someone giving you
a gift and you not saying thank you do
you think they're ever going to give you
a gift ever again no no social media is
supposed to be social it also helps your
algorithm I believe whenever I I respond
this is not very scalable but I respond
myself personally to my comments because
I want to be looking at what people are
saying because it gives me feedback and
data as to what's working and what
people want to hear and what people want
to know so I'd actually use all of this
like non-scalable activity it's not
scalable for me to be in my Instagram
and actually like commenting and and
dming and responding and and and
engaging with people however it gives me
all the information I need to create
more content that works my second tip to
build your brand and to be more visible
and to really stand out from the
competition and being seen is always not
doing it alone but leveraging what I
like to call Opa other people's
audiences so it's really hard to build a
social media platform from scratch when
it's just you it's really hard
especially today with everything that's
going on so why not instead of focusing
on build creating great content yes you
want to do that focus on creating great
relationships focus on using using
social media to connect with people and
build Relationships by providing value
to other people so that then you can get
in front of their audience like we're
doing it right now right like we've
created this connection in this
relationship and now I'm going to get in
front of your audience and then I'm
going to promote this and you're going
to get in front of my audience so that
means that everybody that signed up that
likes you they signed up to get hear
stuff from you to listen to your podcast
to follow your great content they trust
you you are credible to them they have
said yes please me they have raised
their hand so now if you're showcasing
me to them they're going to be like oh
well if Sean likes her then I'm going to
like her too and then they're going to
follow me and that's how you build
faster so that's why the fourth book or
third part of the book is called be
connected because it really all is about
people and connecting and relationships
even though it's virtual even though
it's like this thing that looks like
it's a video game it's real people and
be connected if someone's wondering man
I'm afraid to reach out I want to maybe
guest on other people's podcasts I want
to guest and write an article do you
have any tips in how to structure that
messaging cold
email tactics in are you sliding into
the DMS and maybe mistakes people make
when it comes to networking yes okay so
there's an entire tool in the book
called the top 20 tool and it works
every time no matter what and I will go
into a little bit of it just so that
your listeners have some tactical advice
because a lot of people are going about
pitching completely wrong and I know it
because they're doing it to me and
they're sliding up in my DMs I don't
even know who they are they've done
nothing like to help me or to provide
value I don't know they are and they're
just asking for things and kudos to you
I think that's amazing shoot your shot
ask for what you want yes but there's a
way more strategical way to do it and it
is by always providing value first so
think about who you know and who knows
who knows who knows who knows who knows
who knows who in your community or in
your atmosphere or in your network and
you can usually usually usually get some
connection to somebody that you want
through your network that you have now
and there's a whole system in the book
on how to rank those people how to scale
those people so you actually have
numbers attached to those people and you
can work your list very strategically
but it always starts with giving it
always starts with providing value
because the law of reciprocity is so
unbelievably real and nobody is going to
want to help you if they're just meeting
you for the first time and you're asking
for something right off the bat so I
spend at least 15 minutes of my day and
it's not a lot of time but at least 15
minutes a day no matter what every day
providing value to people whether that
is sharing people's content commenting
on their stuff uh going and writing
reviews for my friends books or my
friend's podcasts and sharing that
review with them and sharing the review
with my followers or even ordering
somebody's course or promoting their
course doing something everybody needs
help with something if you want to make
a connection or a relationship with
somebody figure out how you can help
them and it doesn't have to be Financial
it doesn't have to be a huge form of of
of help and it doesn't have to be like
super grandiose and amazing but it's
like consistent providing value showing
up there is people that I never knew in
my life like I would have never known
them but they show up on my social every
day day and they comment and they share
and they show up on my live and I've for
formed real relationships with these
people and there's some of them who have
come into my DMs after months of like
just showing up for me I'm like I
freaking love you what do you want what
can I help you with and I there's this
one girl and she was she's amazing her
name's Alexis I'm going to shout her out
on this podcast it's going to be huge
for her she's an incredible networker I
want everyone to learn from her we did
not know each other she signed up for my
Mastermind first she started commenting
on all of my stuff she started showing
up on my lives and I just started
noticing her and how much value she was
providing and I'm like I love you I want
to help you because that's just what
happens as humans like when somebody
helps us we want to help them so then
she's like Jen will you write the
forward for my book and normally if I
didn't know her if she wasn't like
really providing value and showing up
and making herself known and making me
feel like please let me help you I don't
know if I would have said yes cuz that's
a big ask I was like hell yeah girl how
else can I help you that's how it works
and that's how I've gotten to where I've
gotten by really focusing on being in
seasons of giving and how can I help
people and a really really important
thing is when you do this and you're
focusing on helping people I don't want
you to call me or DM me call me text me
whatever say Jen I I helped this person
so much and they didn't give me anything
in return number one you're not doing it
with the expectation that they're going
to give you something in return you need
to do it because number one it feels
good to help people so anytime you help
someone h o PE you feel really freaking
amazing so do it because it feels good
number two I believe that when you put
out into the universe and you give you
will get it back in some way shape or
form it doesn't have to come from that
person it doesn't have to come
immediately it will come some way it
will either come from learning something
from giving to that person or maybe
it'll come from a person in a different
relationship with someone else in a
different way but trust and know that
when you give you will receive because
of the law of reciprocity and that is
how you build relationships as a
branding expert I'm curious your hot
takes um as a branding expert what do
you think Taylor Swift has done well in
her branding o
I wish I was a Taylor Swift expert I'm
not uh but just from like watching a
little bit because you can't not watch a
little bit okay Taylor's great at
building community so what I've noticed
and I took a little something something
from Taylor she her her community they
call themselves something they call
themselves swifties so they feel like
they are part of a tribe everybody feels
like they're like very included and
human beings want to be part of
something it's just it's just in us
right we want to feel like we're part of
the club we're part of a tribe part of a
movement and she's done a really really
amazing job in just she's herself she
lets people know what's going on in her
life and you feel like you're one of her
best friends and she calls everybody a
Swifty so it's like I'm a Swifty that's
what I am I am part of this group I am a
Swifty just like you're probably Proud
to be an apple buyer right like you're
not a green text you're a blue text
you're she's you're a Swifty and you are
a DieHard Swifty and you're part of
something and you know like who she's
dating or you know the little like that
like that little thing she dropped in
her song that like nobody else knows
that that's about this one guy because
she like hinted it and you study her and
you know and like you're in with the
cool kids I think she does a really
beautiful job with that and also she is
who she is and she's very honest and
she's very open in her own way um about
like that she's not she's not perfect
she is just a girl she's like your
All-American Girl so she's very very
relatable and um yeah she's also a
freaking expert marketer I I don't know
how she had the most successful tour her
like of all time but she did I'm curious
to know what you think she did to get
that tour to become the most successful
tour of all time I I have no idea all I
know is it is economy shifting it like
has broken some cities football too now
well yeah the whole football thing who's
she dating da she's may be dating a
football player but because of that
tickets are going up his jersey sales
are going up Kyle do you know who that
is I know look up his name so uh
ultimately I think that um I can't I
don't know why she is blowing up so much
it's pretty shocking what is also
impressive is she's reinvented herself
decade after decade because this is not
just her first time she's been
successful but she's on a whole another
level right now and uh they I found it
fascinating that Hospitality restaurants
um hotels uh that economies are lifted
because of that tour unbelievable I've
also been fascinated by the merch lately
of of Niche merch per show and merch
culture cuz it's like limited runs for
certain cities and even the resell of
that and people standing in line who is
it Kel tra Travis from what team say the
Chiefs the Chiefs yeah so so Taylor's
allegedly dat dating Travis from the
Chiefs tickets are going up moms are
bringing their daughters to football
games there's a renewed interest in
football um and it's shocking how much
news media is also like big news outlets
covering like like geopolitics are
talking about Taylor and Travis and uh
it's weird Okay as a branding expert
what are your thoughts on Elon Musk he's
made a lot of branding mistakes you know
and like he's said a lot of things like
smoking weed on Joe Rogan yeah stuff
like that like I do you think that was a
mistake who knows right he's done a lot
of cancel cancelable things yeah but he
doesn't get cancelled cuz it made a lot
of people fall in love with him it made
shareholders and stock value go way down
it like really hurt the company but it's
kind of the enduring thing where some
people are like dude that's so crazy the
CEO doesn't even care you know he has
guts yeah he has the guts to say what he
thinks he has the guts to just he's like
you know what whoever is on board with
this is going to be on board with this
and whoever is not great Sanara and I
think that that's a cool mindset to have
if you are confident enough to have that
mindset and really follow through with
it it can build a very very strong brand
because you want to talk to your ideal
client or customer you want to just like
all of your people that love you they're
going to follow they're going to love it
and the people that don't then they're
going to go follow somebody else and if
you're if you're speaking to all people
you're speaking to nobody so he speaks
to his person and you're either a fan or
you're not I guess so do you think that
obviously polar being polarizing can be
a powerful aspect of building a brand
but do you think anything like these
different things should not be tactics
but they should be just you being
authentically who you are that you
should not try to Leverage polarization
or controversy unless of course that's
kind you that's just genuinely who you
are yeah it all whenever you're trying
to like Leverage some kind of trick yeah
I don't think it works because it's hard
to keep that up and people can sense
Liars now from a million miles away and
it's just not authentic and I for me
personally look listen do you this is
all just like my personal opinion I like
to follow authentic people and if your
truth is that you're polarizing person
yeah then yeah amazing good for you and
there's going to be people that freaking
love that and there's going to be people
that hate it and that's great and that's
who you are whoever you are that's who
you should be online uh but you know
there is cancel culture right now which
which has comes into play right there's
a lot of fear around that do you think
people should be worried about counil
Council culture and thoughtful or
cautious in their messaging let me keep
the question going there's a huge
phenomenon in YouTube culture and
celebrity culture of apology
videos they almost always go bad oh
really there's people reacting to
YouTuber apology videos and people react
and they're like it's obviously it's
stage whether it is or it isn't they
think it is negative comments it wasn't
authentic they get dissected then
reacted to by other channels sometimes
they get reacted to by psychologists or
like lie detector people but I'm curious
I don't know if you've heard the story
now of Ashton Kutcher and
meais um being cancelled for writing a
letter of endorsement
to their friend who was I don't think
just allegedly I think he was convicted
of
rape and
he they did an apology video which got
torn to
shreds um and did not even help their
case you also could see Drew Barrymore
who during writer strike and actor
strike decided to launch her show and of
course there was some limitations
but apparently she wasn't violating
those but she still maybe missed the
spirit of it all put up an apology video
and inevitably 9 times out of 10 the the
video gets deleted it doesn't matter
because the internet's undefeated
there's no way to delete a video really
off the internet because then it's still
out there and so these types of now
celebrities which like you said could
happen to anybody experience cancel
culture thoughts on all of the above and
how we should be thoughtful in our maybe
small spheres of influence about
navigating a world in which cancel
culture is so prevalent yeah it's hard I
think about this all the time I have to
be real in this conversation this is a
this is a hard world that we live in it
really is especially if you're a content
creator or you're a celebrity or you're
a public figure and everything that you
say and do is very scrutinized it's very
it's every single thing right there's
people you know on YouTube that tear
apart like every like little thing that
anybody says and and looks for the thing
and so it's a thing and we can't live
our lives being scared every day that
we're going to get canceled because that
is no way to live and then we're we're
not going to show up and we're not going
to be seen because there's so many
things that you could be afraid of and
and then you're going to be way too like
buttoned up and like way too afraid and
there's going to be a lot of fear behind
your content and that's never fun and
that's not good but at the same time you
want to be thoughtful about the things
that you're saying of course uh and and
make sure that what you're saying is
from your heart and what you believe in
but listen if you're I don't know if if
you're a bad person and you want bad for
the world and you're sharing that online
then then that's what that's what you're
signing up for
and it's hard to even I'm nav like we're
all navigating this for the first time
right now I'd love to hear because
you're in the YouTube space hardcore
like what are you telling your clients
and content creators to do with this
cancel culture thing that's happening
well I think there's two groups of
people I think on the one group of
people that are in our community there's
not a lot of danger of cancel culture
because they teach a particular skill
they're a DIY channel they teach
programming if you do camera reviews you
do some different things like that like
your this the nature of your content
that's also probably a reflection of
your personality it's kind of
uncan it's just more neutral now that
there's a whole other group where we
have this conversation in our community
of Shadow
Banning um YouTube does seem and all the
social media platforms sometimes lean a
little more liberal so sometimes
conservative news or conservative
channels either are experiencing or
think they could be experiencing some
level of Shadow Banning on either side I
think what people get canceled for is if
they are maybe stepping into the realm
of politics religion relationships they
move into those world you know and and
we're living in a defi very last couple
uh years I think we've all seen it it's
sad really because culture is being
polarized Society is it's really
becoming like kind of two ided
everyone's on extremes not very a w not
a very wise place to be and I think
social media is guilty of that as well
because the algorithm rewards extremes
and it doesn't reward a lot of vanilla
here's what's interesting that's going
to start happening with AI though is
there's going to be deep fakes uh that
are going to be created and they're
going to be showcasing people saying
things that maybe they didn't say and
I'm really curious to what's going to
happen when that starts taking place
yeah and and I guess it already is
because you'll see accounts of Donald
Trump you'll see accounts of Joe Rogan I
saw a Joe Rogan one talking about a time
when he was partying with Andrew Tate
and he's like we were in and and there
he was behind the mic and like so you
couldn't see his lips but the AI like
the AI reading a script and it was said
in such a way where the person he was
talking to seemed like a story that
normally Joe Rogan would relate and
subtle so I think if you make an extreme
deep fake somebody go ah it's obviously
fake it's very subtle like and and it
built up to where he ultimately like
caught Andrew Tate saying I would never
touch cocaine and then he caught him
doing cocaine in a bathroom um and
what's actually interesting was I was
passively hearing this like what and
then the comments themselves there was
people like oh my gosh he was caught
sure enough and then a bunch of comments
like I can't believe people think this
is real it's obvious and it actually I
had to double take and this just hit my
YouTube shorts feed and natur it's being
shared in the YouTube shorts feed Etc so
that's a great Point what's your advice
for us moving forward West it's the Wild
Wild West I don't have advice um I you
know be a kind person yeah that's my
advice always yeah be kind be a good
person be a good human being and you
have a better shot at like just you know
not getting cancelled yeah be good be
who you are and I always lead with
kindness and if you don't know something
say you don't know something if you
don't have an opinion say you don't have
if you have an opinion but know that if
you are going to go there MH that
there's a shot that people are going to
not like it they're going to say things
about it and just be prepared what is
your relationship with that ask yourself
okay as we land the plane we have a new
segment called repeat after me and uh I
will say the statement you say the
statement as well it might be
self-explanatory and then you finish the
statement so if I was starting on social
media from zero today the first thing I
would do is if I was starting on social
media from zero today the first thing
that I would do is I would connect with
people that I know that already have a
platform full of people that are my
ideal client Avatar my ideal audience
and I would ask them if we can
collaborate and do something where they
can put me in front of their audience so
that I could start to build my following
with people that are actually interested
in hearing from me and the topic that I
talk about because the person that talks
about a similar topic or has that
audience showcased me in front of those
people and double tapped and said this
person's credible I would do that with
10 20 30 40 50 people I would focus my
entire first year on getting in front of
other people's audiences whether that's
podcasts or Instagram lives or Tik Tok
lives or Facebook lives or speaking on
their physical stages um or teaching
their communities and I would double
down on relationship building and
getting in front of people's audiences
if I wanted to strengthen my brand I
would pull out a piece of paper and I
would start answering these questions if
I wanted to strengthen my brand I would
pull out a piece of paper and I would
start answering these questions what is
the thing that I love to do so so much
that when I'm doing it time stands still
I would answer that question what is the
thing that people ask me the most about
what's the question they ask me the most
about what's the thing about myself that
they ask me the most about and then what
is the thing that most people tell me
I'm really good at that's hard for them
the biggest mistake I see people making
on social media right now is we answered
this already but I'll do it again the
there's two the biggest mistake I see
people make on social media now is a not
being consistent and just falling off
the track and and not posting every day
and not posting enough and then number
two it's not engaging with their people
it's not actually having conversations
just posting and ghosting and making it
like it's a magazine instead of a social
network if you're feeling afraid to get
on camera just if you're feeling afraid
to get on camera just think about the
one person on the other side of the
camera that you're having a conversation
with picture your best friend your
partner your child someone that you
absolutely love your favorite client and
just have a conversation with them
because we never get nervous when we're
just sitting having a conversation with
somebody but suddenly when a camera's in
front of us we get nervous so take a
photo of that person and put it next to
the camera or Envision that that
person's face is right behind that
camera and talk to one person help one
person every day my number one
networking tip is my number one
networking tip is to be the most
interested person rather than trying to
be the most interesting person brilliant
Jen tell us a little bit about the book
and how we can connect with you follow
up with you um and uh what you got going
on the book yay the book comes out
October 31st so depending on when airs
you can either pre-order it at bseen
book.com or anywhere you get books uh or
you can get it on October 31st and it's
not just for business owners it's not
just for entrepreneurs it's actually for
anybody that wants to start being seen
as who they really are so they can build
the life that they really love and
there's tactical stuff in there but
there's a lot of stories that I don't
typically tell and they're all in there
and it's all my learnings my process of
being seen throughout my life and my
face plants and what I've learned from
them and how you can not do what I did
and step-by-step processes to build your
brand and if people want to connect with
you online where are you at I'm mostly
just Instagram is where I hang out the
most so _ gotle 1n Jen thank you so much
for coming on the th media podcast this
was so fun thank you for having me